down and walk 500 miles and I would walk
500.
oh wow I mean wow crying first of all
Gwen Stefani keeps crying on the voice
for good reasons I wasn't ready
the latest tearful moment happened
during the top 13 round of live shows
contestant Bodhi from Gwen's hubby Blake
Shelton's team saying I'm gonna be 500
Miles by The Proclaimers which was his
wedding song with his wife
and I know I'm gonna be I'm gonna be the
man slowly without you
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
and the combo of the vocals the music
and the story pulled on Gwen's
Heartstrings
oh wow I mean wow crying first of all
second of all you are so unbelievably
gifted you're so talented and I think
what your voice is ridiculous but what I
loved about tonight and what you do is
you have so much access to your heart
like it's so real I believe you so much
um I can't believe you're not like a
huge star yet like let's go guys as for
bodies coach Blake the country star
predicted ahead of bodhi's performance
he would deliver excellence and even
dropped some High Praise I mean he's
made me look at these lyrics in a way
that I never had before Bodhi is a
Visionary I had a couple thoughts that's
what makes him the most unique artist
I've ever worked with
but booty isn't the only contestant
bringing Gwen to tears this season I'm
trying to live in the Moment Justin
Aaron who's on team gwent closed out the
show singing Break Every Chain a track
he says helped him work through
depression
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
that is Justin Aaron who closes it out
here as a top 13 all trying to move on
not only did Justin move Quinn he also
touched fellow coach John Legend you
keep showing us more and more of who you
are and your ability and it's incredible
to watch you're amazing Justin I can't
even speak I'm in awe of you I'm so
excited to be able to be part of this
with you I just know that I have an
incredible team this season I always do
but I feel like there's something really
different about this season overall I
just feel like it's been a really
relaxed season so the talent's clearly
there on both Team Blake and team Gwen
and as Blake told E.T ahead of the
Season he just hopes one of them brings
home the W this year did you feel more
competitive or less competitive how
would you categorize it more or less
more competitive you gotta win for the
household yeah
foreign